right now there's only one way to fill
the hole and the RAF are on it
a precise operation to drop tons of
ballast into the part of the wall that
was ripped away by the weather all day
Laurie watched the RAF relay she lives
on the side of Todd Brook reservoir
under the new flight path I feel
completely wired it feels very very
threatening really and I think I really
feel for the people who have been
flooded out and the people who've been
evacuated fire crews are sucking
millions of liters out every hour but
such as the size of this reservoir the
water level will drop by just a meter a
day everyone is asking will it be enough
I can't Carla as a as a firefighter
while we can do is get the water rate
for you at this stage there are no
guarantees I would say now the middle of
Whaley bridge is now deserted the brown
railway line between Buxton and
Stockport is closed homes businesses all
abandoned million Courtney run the
bridge bake house in town I went home
straight from work still around the
corner just grabbed as much the cord and
then they wouldn't let me drive up the
hills try to leave my car my animal
everything and just get get up here
really put the dumb brakes then the the
shop is just in the line of the actual
rush of water apparently and it would
just
so you've just got to you've got to be
you got to look on the bright side I've
ever been yeah because otherwise you're
just over thing from then I don't know
what but as long as everyone's safe that
is all that matters really so they wait
just hoping the water pumping relieves
the pressure once you get a breach if
any water retaining structure
particularly a gravity dam like this you
will get scouring action very quickly
and the breach will expand and you will
get large amounts of water which would
flood the village and possibly some of
the buildings in the immediate vicinity
of the foot of the dam could suffer
severe structural damage it's the worst
case scenario that's spurring this
mission on the longer it holds the more
confident they become but the situation
is still critical it will be days before
they can say that it is safe Tom
Parmenter Sky News Derbyshire